[Musique]
sensation sensation le mag bonjour à
tous bienvenue sur sensation en
association avec TV 78 je suis
aujourd'hui avec Marie Raphaël minier
manager du centre rock direct à
Saint-Germain-en-Laye on va parler
ensemble du plan ripower u bonjour
bonjour alors avant cela j'aimerais
qu'on parle du Centre Europe Direct il
était Bergé par la Maison de l'Europe
des Yvelines de Saint-Germain-en-Laye
quels sont les ambitions de la ndeey et
du centre rock direct au quotidien alors
c'est vraiment rapproché les citoyens de
l'Union européenne notamment de la
Commission européenne qui finance et
soutient les centres-rope direct
afin de porter les messages les
directives les vulgariser les amener au
grand public et faire également remonter
l'opinion du grand public auprès des
élus de Bruxelles donc vous suivez les
dispositifs et les actions adoptés par
par la Commission européenne pour les
développer c'est ce que vous venez de
dire sur le territoire des des Yvelines
pour informer les Yvelinois quels sont
par exemple les actions que vous avez
mis en place ces dernières années en
lien avec l'Union européenne alors cette
année on va être amené à traiter l'Année
européenne des compétences et des
talents qui est une des directives aussi
énoncées par Ursula vanderleyen au
moment de son discours sur l'état de
l'Union pour mettre en avant les
compétences essentiellement des jeunes
et paliers à la crise de l'emploi
on va traiter bien évidemment la
transition énergétique
le suivi du conflit en Ukraine
mais également la sensibilisation à la
désinformation et voilà tous les sujets
en fait qui sont au cœur des politiques
européennes alors cette année la
Commission européenne propose donc le
plan ripower U à quel besoin répondez
justement la mise en place de ce
dispositif en fait c'est le projet de la
Commission européenne qui vise à mettre
fin à la dépendance des importations de
combustibles fossiles en provenance de
Russie suite au déclenchement du conflit
ukrainien donc c'est donc au travers de
l'invasion Ukraine par la Russie et les
difficultés d'approvisionnement en
énergie qu'on a qu'on a du coup tous
connu l'objectif de l'Union européenne
c'est donc de réussir à produire sa
propre énergie et devenir indépendante
notamment face à la Russie oui
absolument et surtout à se diversifier
et à trouver d'autres partenaires
internationaux d'autres sources
d'approvisionnement énergétiques
produire sa propre énergie et
autant que possible vraiment
arrêter ces importations massives de gaz
en provenance de Russie et d'énergie
fossile en général vous l'avez dit un
produit à sa propre énergie de l'énergie
propre également également l'économiser
qu'est-ce que ça signifie ce que
l'Europe va devoir procéder à une
refonte de son système énergétique
absolument une refonte une des
délocalisations des investissements
supplémentaires et surtout un effort à
la fois des entreprises désorganisations
et des citoyens donc c'est vraiment une
modification profonde globale presque
systémique du système
d'approvisionnement énergétique ce
conflit finalement en
Ukraine ça nous a permis en tant que en
tant qu'Européen en tant que l'Union
européenne de nous dire on est beaucoup
trop dépendant finalement des autres
[Musique]
et il est encore c'est qu'on est d'une
part dépendant de pays du coup instable
sur le plan politique et surtout on est
peu diversifié on a tout misé sur un
seul type de retour ressources et
maintenant au-delà du conflit ukrainien
quid de l'environnement et qu'est-ce
qu'on fait pour produire mieux et plus
proprement
aux entreprises mais également aux
citoyens l'idée c'est déjà donc de
modifier nos comportements afin
d'économiser l'énergie absolument alors
on dit souvent que ce sont les grandes
entreprises qui polluent et que ce ne
sont pas les petits écogestes de chaque
citoyen qui vont changer la donne mais
je suis vraiment convaincue que si tout
le monde fait un effort sans changer la
donne cette modification va entraîner
des comportements plus vertueux ces
comportements plus vertueux vont générer
d'autres types de consommation qui vont
inciter les entreprises à fournir une
nouvelle offre donc les entreprises
c'est également ça c'est les tendent
finalement vers des comportements
également plus exactement faut
finalement qu'elle donne un exemple déjà
au niveau européen au niveau des
entreprises et ensuite des citoyens
absolument et surtout qu'elle donne un
exemple c'est ce que souhaite démontrer
l'Union européenne et c'est le but de
l'Union européenne c'est la
mutualisation des ressources c'est
qu'est-ce que les entreprises peuvent
faire ensemble qu'est-ce que les pays de
l'Union Européenne peuvent faire
ensemble pour pallier à cette crise et
les ressources internationales restent
tout de même essentielles pour répondre
aux besoins énergétiques de l'Europe
mais l'Union européenne doit tout de
même apprendre à devenir un peu plus
indépendante ça c'est ça l'idée c'est un
peu plus indépendante ou totalement
indépendante presque totalement
indépendante on sera jamais totalement
indépendant étape par état mais au sein
des 27 je pense qu'on peut tendre à une
indépendance quasi totale alors c'est
pas seulement une question d'entraide
c'est aussi apprendre à produire des
énergies propres comme le biométhane ou
l'hydrogène
et l'idée ce serait de réduire
de 17 milliards si je oui c'est ça 17
milliards de mètres cubes les
importations de gaz et ça déjà ce serait
énorme donc l'objectif maintenant c'est
surtout de tendre vers les énergies
renouvelables que permet le plan ripower
you sur la thématique de la transition
écologique en terme d'énergie
renouvelable alors l'idée c'est déjà de
stimuler ce qu'on appelle la
décarbonation industrielle c'est de
permettre financièrement avec une
enveloppe conséquente aux entreprises de
passer à d'autres types et d'énergie
parce qu'aucune entreprise ne va dire ok
on y va si elle n'a pas le support
financier qui va lui permettre de
survivre à ça ça va être de nouvelles
législations puisque on ne pourra pas
manier sur le plan juridique de
l'hydrogène ou du biométhane comme du
gaz du charbon de l'électricité etc
c'est augmenter l'efficacité énergétique
c'est-à-dire produire moins pour
chauffer ou conduire plus par exemple
et c'est aussi je vous parlais de
l'hydrogène des initiatives ce qu'on a
appelé accélérateur d'hydrogène pour
monter à 17 gigawh et demi en 2025 donc
vous avez parlé justement des
initiatives des entreprises pour tendre
vers cette transition écologique donc ça
veut dire qu'aujourd'hui une entreprise
qui aimerait tant de vers la transition
écologique mais qui n'a pas forcément
les moyens peut demander une aide à
l'Union européenne pour réussir cet
objectif là grâce au plan ripower you
oui absolument puisque le fond
d'innovation va être doté de 3 milliards
d'euros supplémentaires et les crédits
ne vont pas s'arrêter là la Commission
européenne indique que justement des
investissements supplémentaires de 210
milliards d'euros sont nécessaires d'ici
à 2027 pour nous défaire de la
dépendance des importations de
combustible fossiles russes en 2027
c'est quand même dans quelques années
que propose la Commission européenne
pour atteindre justement cette cet
objectif est-ce qu'il est pas un peu
trop grand cet objectif non il a même il
est même je pense réalisable plus
facilement qu'on ne le pensait puisque
beaucoup d'importations se sont arrêtés
dès cet hiver
on a tous vu les plans de la Commission
européenne on a tous à un moment ou un
autre entendu parler d'Ursula Vander
leyenne qui disait voilà il y aura pas
de coupure cet hiver parce que si parce
que mi alors c'est très compliqué et
c'est dur de rentrer dans les détails
mais effectivement contrairement à ce
qu'on pensait on n'a pas souffert de
coupure d'électricité sauvage ou de gaz
etc donc finalement
ce côté il faut beaucoup de raisonnable
à fonctionner donc moi je suis vraiment
très optimiste sur ce qu'on peut faire à
horizon 2027 ou 2030 et quand l'Union
européenne nous dit on va passer à 45%
d'énergie renouvelable dès 2030 vraiment
j'en suis convaincu et le plan ripower
you on risque donc d'en entendre parler
rapidement par le gouvernement ou par le
Président de la République oui je pense
que oui puisque les entreprises
françaises vont être amenées comme les
entreprises des 27 autres États de
l'Union à
mettre en oeuvre des changements
profonds et systémiques a peut-être
devoir réenvisager la formation de son
personnel donc ça ça va aussi avec
l'Année européenne des compétences donc
le gouvernement va falloir devoir
communiquer pour que les gens ne soient
pas pris au dépourvu et s'imaginent que
c'est un faisable et qu'est-ce que vous
allez faire vous du coup au Centre
Europe Direct pour justement informer
les citoyens tout au long de tout au
long de l'année ce que vous allez mettre
des actions en place alors on va faire
des émissions de radio pour essayer de
répondre à des questions et voilà toutes
plaisant mise à part on a une conférence
qui est prévue avec le quai des
possibles qui inter lieu important du
développement durable sur la zone de
Saint-Germain-en-Laye et qui organise un
week-end par mois des sessions un deux
trois planètes où ils mettent en avant
des acteurs du territoire qui proposent
de nouvelles pratiques donc d'ici la fin
de l'année 2023 on va faire un samedi
entier avec eux différents acteurs du
territoire
l'Agence nationale de cohésion des
territoires
des entreprises des membres de la
société civile pour vraiment mutualiser
les actions du territoire et les faire
connaître du grand public alors on va
synthétiser dans le temps qui nous reste
tout nos propos et surtout voir les
solutions et les mesures quand on parle
du plan ripower you qu'est-ce que ça
signifie et quels sont les mesures à
court terme alors à court terme on les a
déjà
vécu j'ai envie de vous dire puisque la
première était de réduire les
importations de 80% à horizon novembre
2022 donc ça ça y est c'est fait les
mesures à moyen terme c'est vraiment
stimuler la décarbonation industrielle
investir dans un réseau adapté
d'infrastructures de gaz et
d'électricité
accélérer les propositions pour des
énergies propres comme carbone biométone
et méthane etc
et surtout proposer un cadre
réglementaire adapté à toutes ces
mesures on suivra de toute façon tout au
long de l'année justement ce plan
ripower you et dans les prochaines
années parce qu'il va pas s'arrêter fin
2023 merci beaucoup Marie Raphaël minier
d'avoir été avec nous sur sensation je
rappelle que vous êtes manager du Centre
Europe Direct à Saint-Germain-en-Laye
pour plus d'informations on peut se
rendre sur le site maison Europe 78.u et
pour revoir ou réécouter cette émission
rendez-vous sur notre site et notre
application radio sensation
[Musique]